Перше, що цікавить батьків, які хочуть вийти на роботу,
де і як залишити свою дитину під наглядом?
В Німеччині існує дві можливості -
дитсадок або няня - Tagesmutter.
Як дитячі садки, так і няні пропонують, як правило,
догляд із 9 до 16 години.
У великих дитсадках виховательки працюють у дві зміни -
тоді дітей можна приводити
вже о 7 ранку і забирати о 18 годині,
утім це швидше виняток, ніж правило.
Із нянею куди простіше домовитись про індивідуальний графік.
Вона гнучкіша, адже доглядає меншу групу дітей -
зазвичай від двох до п'ятьох.
Витрати батьків на дитсадок варіюються
від 0 євро і  до багатьох тисяч на рік.
Залежно від регіону Німеччини, заробітку батьків,
часу догляду, віку дитини або дітей, інших чинників.
Ось приклад. Родина у західнонімецькому Бохумі з річним доходом
до 60 тисяч євро заплатить близько 100 євро на місяць
за одну дитину віком старше 2 років
за 25 годин садка на тиждень.
А за 45 годин і дитиною до 2 років -
вже 300 євро на місяць
При цьому гроші, сплачені за дитсадок,
можна списувати з податків.
Якщо родина віддає у дитсадок одночасно другу дитину -
то отримує велику знижку.
У деяких землях садки безкоштовні.
Утім, це не враховує витрат на харчування, додаткові матеріали для майстрування,
уроки музики або іноземних мов тощо.
Чи дорогі послуги няні,
про доплату за яку заговорив уряд в Україні?
В Німеччині це задоволення не з дешевих
і влаштовує радше тих батьків, у яких немає іншого виходу -
їхній час роботи ніяк не вписується у графік роботи дитсадків.
Няня, яка доглядає вашу дитину 7 годин на день,
обійдеться щонайменше у 500-700 євро на місяць.
Громади передбачили різні доплати родинам,
залежно від рівня доходів, а із дуже низькими заробітками
є можливість повної компенсації оплати няні.
У дитсадків є, як правило, чітка педагогічна концепція.
Існують садки із музично-мистецьким ухилом чи білінгвістичні.
Зовсім нестандартним підходом відрізняються дошкільні заклади
Вальдорфської педагогіки або Монтессорі
які вчать творчо і критично мислити.
Щодо нянь, то настільки різноманітної педагогічної програми
у них очікувати не варто,
попри те, що вони сертифіковані і працюють з відповідним дозволом.
Зате няня може приділити більше уваги окремій дитині
і краще реалізувати уявлення батьків про її виховання.
Із близько 60 тисяч дитсадків у Німеччині
більшість - не комунальні, а приватні.
Від форми власника залежить як матеріальне забезпечення закладу,
так і смислове наповнення занять.
Наприклад, релігійні громади - католицькі чи протестантські -
утримують майже третину усіх дитсадків
і очікують виховання молоді у християнських традиціях.
Утім, батькам у Німеччині - не до висунення претензій.
Адже місця у німецьких дитсадках - дефіцит.
Хоча з 2013 року вони гарантуються батькам законом.
Вихователі і родини через це нерідко страйкують.
Як нещодавно у столиці Берліні, де бракує 2,5 тис місць для дітлахів.
Тож не дивно, що чимало німецьких родин
подають заявку до дитсадка ще до того, як народиться дитина.